ANKUR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to the Android
Developer Lab+.
This week we're going to be
talking about notifications.
And this is actually our second
run time through,
because we seem to have some
technical difficulties.
So hopefully we get it
right this time.
And with that being said, let's
move on to news before
we talk about notifications.
So news for this week is
that we've launched a
new developer console.
So if you've ever published an
Android app before, or if
you've even registered as an
Android developer, you can go
to your developer console or
your publisher console now.
And you can enable
the new console.
It's something that we've been
working very hard towards.
We announced its beta
at Google I/O three
months ago in June.
Actually, it's been over
three months ago.
It was at the end of June.
So three and half months ago.
And we're thrilled that
we can finally
launch it to the world.
We've had some very
positive feedback.
But we want to continue
to hear your feedback.
So if there's something that you
feel could be better, we
definitely want you to send
us that feedback.
The other thing we want to
announce is that we now
support a couple new
buyer currencies in
India and in Russia.
So you can actually now, when
you publish your apps, you can
specify the local price
that users will
pay in those countries.
This is not seller support,
so don't get that
part mixed up yet.
We're still working
hard towards that.
But this is a good first
stepping stone for Indian
users and Russian users.
So next slide, please.
Last week we announced something
that we call ADL+
experiments.
And ADL+ experiments is
basically a way for Android
developers to get involved in
some of the APIs that we
present here on ADL+.
So we're hoping that this is the
first of many experiments.
And basically what it is is that
last week we presented on
the connectivity APIs--
or Anirudh presented.
So we're asking you to build
something cool with those
connectivity APIs and
showcase it to the
Android developer community.
So submit away.
What you need to do is add +ADL+
Experiments on Google+.
There's a shortened URL there.
But you can just do a search
for it on Plus, too.
And basically add that page,
build your app, your APK.
Share it with that Plus page.
And let us know how we
should use your app,
what makes it cool.
So we've set up a cut off date
of the 30th of October.
So it gives you several
weeks to build it.
And it doesn't have to
be totally polished.
It's really about the creative
concepts that
we're looking at.
And the apps that we find to be
most creative, we will try
and bring those developers on
ADL+ in a future episode.
We're trying to showcase
your app.
And yeah, we really want to be
just surprised and impressed
by the creativity of
this community.
So with that being said, I'm
going to now hand it over to
Tony, who's going to talk
about notifications.
TONY: Thank you, Ankur.
So today our presentation
is about notifications.
And so before we defer to the
details, let's do an overview
of what notification is for.
So notification is really a
feature to allow developers to
display messages to the user
outside of your application
user interface.
And also keep the user informed
about some important
events that requires immediate
attention.
Another use case of notification
is you can use it
as a log in Android that
chronicles events while the
user is not using the phone
or paying attention.
So when to use a display
of notification?
So the primary use case is
really time sensitive events.
And also usually these kind of
events also involve other
people to the phone owner.
Some other use cases could be
using a notification for
asynchronous or undirected
information.
But in these cases, we recommend
developer to allow
user to opt in or opt out to
that kind of notification.
So when not to display
a notification?
So there are actually quite a
few scenarios you probably
don't want to use
notification.
One example is if the user is
already in your application,
and the information you want
to be present in the
notification is already
currently on the screen, don't
create a notification.
So also, low level technical
operations shouldn't be
included in notifications
as well.
And sometimes, like when you
have errors that your
application can recover, those
are the stuff that are
probably not a good candidate
for notification.
And finally, if you just think
about presenting a
notification just manually to
advertise your application or
just create brand awareness,
those are not good candidates
for notification again.
And in those cases, you probably
want to consider
building a widget in order to
keep your user engaged with
your application.
So what's new in Jelly
Bean in terms of
notification features?
So one main thing we introduced
in Jelly Bean is we
added rich notification
support.
And I will talk in detail
about that later.
Another important thing
developers should be aware of
is now in Jelly Bean later,
the user can now disable
notification per application.
So that really actually gives
developers an incentive to do
notification properly.
Because now the user can
completely disable your
notification.
Another nice thing we add in
notification in Jelly Bean is
we added priority.
So in the past, developer has
to be probably choose to use
[? ongoing ?] notification
in order to keep their
notifications sticky
on the screen.
But now we have a better
mechanism to handle different
kind of notification in
different priority.
So notification,
we [INAUDIBLE].
Before we talk about rich
notification, let's talk about
the standard, basic layout
for notification.
So this is what we have priority
on Jelly Bean.
So it's really a few
components in the
notification--
the content title, there's
a large icon on the left.
And also you can put some text
under the title, and also
sometimes content information.
In the lower right corner,
you can add a small icon.
And also the time of
your notification.
So next, we'll talk about
rich notification.
So this is again introducing
Jelly Bean.
And now one thing kind of
special is in the past, you
needed to create a custom
view to create actions.
But now actions are really first
class citizen in the
notification framework.
It also is a lot more flexible
in terms of size
and size and layout.
It can grow up to 256dp in
height, which is what we call
four units of notifications.
So in the past, it was 64dp
per notification.
So you can have up to four times
the size of notification
you can use.
We added priority, so five
different type of priority.
And again use those priorities
responsibly.
So this is the big view I
was mentioning for rich
notification.
So pretty much, we still have
all the old components,
existing components.
But we added a new component
called detail
areas for the big view.
ANKUR: Yeah, I just want to--
sorry, Tony--
I just want to emphasize there
that notifications are--
originally, they were just
being used as a way to
showcase instantaneous
information.
Like hey, you have an
instant message.
But you can see with all of this
capability that we are
adding into rich notifications,
it's a lot more
than just conveying instant
information.
You can see here in this screen
shot, we can see the
list of Gmail conversations.
Tony talked about the
fact that we can
have actions on there.
What that really means is that
users are able to interact
with your app without actually
switching into your app.
So it's a really great way to
keep them engaged without
having them go in and out
of apps all the time.
TONY: Yeah.
So you really want to, for some
of the simple tasks that
users can quickly handle within
the notifications--
those are actually what the
action buttons are for.
And for the complex task, it's
still recommended to redirect
the user to your application
to do the [INAUDIBLE]
complex tasks.
And for simple stuff, you can
really enhance the user
experience if you create
actions within the
notification.
So let's talk about how to
create a simple notification.
So one thing we add later in
our API is we now have a
builder to build notification.
And we also introduce
something called
NotificationCompat in
the support library.
So that makes your notification
implementation
backward compatible.
It's not in the sense like order
in which notification
feature will be available in
the older Android versions.
But it has to make sure your
code will not break in
[INAUDIBLE].
There are a couple of required
contents in forming a
notification.
So a small icon, a title,
and the detail text.
This is a code snippet on how
to use builder to build a
simple notification.
So the next thing I want to go
through is how to create a big
view, so the rich
notification UI.
So it turns out we
have a new style.
We make it really easy
for developers to
create these big views.
So we have a few templates.
So one of them is called
inbox style.
So you can use the compatibility
library class
inbox style.
Create [INAUDIBLE] of that.
And then you can add the content
title for the big
view, which is a replacement of
the regular content title.
And then you can add new
lines with the details.
And then set the inbox style as
the style you use for big
content view.
So there are other styles, as
I mentioned, available.
One is called the big
picture style.
So if you are building some
social network style like
application or photo application
that has a lot of
pictures, you can consider
using the picture style.
Big text, again, of course is if
you have more text you want
to display, that's probably
what you want to use.
And if your application actually
involves multiple
messages or information, you
can use the inbox style.
So here is kind of a breakdown
of things like how each
different style, what is
available in each style.
So title is really for
a notification.
In the normal view, we use
set content title.
And for all the big views,
we are using
set big content title.
It's merely a replacement of the
set content title content.
Small icon is available
throughout all the
normal and big view.
One caveat we noticed is in
order to have that small icon
to show up on the screen,
you really need to
set the summary text.
So large icons would be
available across all different
style, again.
And for content text--
so normal style, you use
set content text.
But for big text, it's actually
not available.
For big text, we have a special
method called big text
that allows a developer to
add the big chunk of
text in the big view.
Big picture is also, again,
only available in the big
picture style.
And finally, the summary
text is available
in all the big views.
This is kind of a nice summary
of what's available in
different styles.
ANKUR: I totally agree, Tony.
This is actually a really,
really useful summary that you
could spend some time trying
to find this sort of
information.
So it's really useful.
One other thing that I'll just
add with the inbox style, is
that you can actually add
multiple lines of text.
There's a method called
add line.
And it's quite interesting
in the way that it works.
Whereas with big text, it'll
actually automatically wrap
the line, and try and put as
much of the text in that view
as possible.
With inbox, what it will do
is, for each line, if that
line is too long, it won't
wrap the line.
It will ellipse size it.
So basically what that means is,
it will truncate the text
and put a dot, dot, dot at
the end of each line.
So just a subtle difference
there
that's also worth noting.
TONY: Yep.
Thanks, Ankur.
So one thing probably you want
to pay attention is when the
user actually click on the
notification, you really want
to preserve the backstep
and the navigation.
So here's how it works.
You create an intent.
You want to create
a pending intent.
That's actually what you do when
you launch something from
notification.
But there's one additional step
you need to do, is to
create a TaskStackBuilder to
add the previous activity
before in the backstep.
So that when the user hits the
back button, it won't just go
back to the home screen.
But instead, going to your
application, just normally
what the user would experience
when he or she is using your
application.
So that's one thing you
need to pay attention.
I just want to talk a little
bit about removing
notifications.
So there are a couple ways
you can do removing of
notifications.
So of course, the user
can do this manually.
But when you're building a
notification, if you set
AutoCancel, this will
automatically dismiss your
notification when the user
actually touches the
notification.
Of course again, the user can
swipe left or right to create
a notification.
Or they simply click the
Clear All button.
Also programmatically
in your application,
you can use two methods--
a cancel method provided with
the perimeter of the
notification ID.
Or you can cancel all the
notifications you create.
So this is particularly useful
when you want to handle your
notifications intelligently.
We talk about that in some of
our talks before, to create
intelligent notifications.
Like one example is, if there
are some events that are
already in the past, like
it could be a calendar
application, you may want to
actually remove some of the
[INAUDIBLE]
and notification because it's
already passed the event.
So these methods will be useful
for taking care of
expired notifications.
So just to summarize again.
So one thing is use
notifications judiciously.
Primarily, you want to only
use notification for time
sensitive information or things
that involve people.
And keep in mind to make
notification optional.
Because as now in Jelly Bean
or later, a user can
completely disable it.
So your apps should not have
really features that are only
available through actions
in the notifications.
So that's very important.
And finally, use
NotificationCompat in the
support library to take out
backward compatibility.
ANKUR: I just want to add to
the comment that Tony said
about using them judiciously.
An example of a way you would
call it a bad use of
notifications is if you have
an app that preloads or
refreshes every so often, it's
not a good idea to use a
notification to say hey, I'm
doing this in the background.
I'm fetching your next set of
emails or your news feed.
That sort of information's
fairly superfluous.
It's the kind of information
that you could choose if you
wanted to show it within your
app, but the notification is
certainly not the place where
you would do that.
There are exceptions where it's
something like a download.
Because a download is something
that a user has
explicitly initiated.
So in a web browser, for
example, there it kind of
makes a little bit more sense.
Because they might be waiting
for that file to come through.
But certainly, you shouldn't be
doing it just for periodic
updates or anything like that.
Those two points about being
time sensitive and involving
either the user or people that
the user is familiar with,
it's quite an important point.
TONY: Right.
So two things that can help you,
if you are really worried
about the user experience.
So two things that can help you
to do is to address that
is, one, have a setting in
your application to make
notification or some of the
notifications opt-in or optional.
So the user has a
choice to do it.
The other thing is if you
think some of the
notifications may be too low
level or not directly
relevant, consider using a low
priority notification.
Let the system, let the
framework handle those things
properly for you.
ANKUR: Yeah, actually one
of the games we recently
featured, I think it was last
week or maybe the week before,
called Kingdoms of Camelot, I
was trying this game out.
And it's sort of like a
Farmville-type clone set up in
a fantasy world.
So you're building farms and
you're training armies and
researching better
swords and so on.
They had an interesting
use of notifications.
Where, because the game is very
much based on real time,
it'll say something like,
you can only build
one building at once.
And it's going to take two
hours to build it.
They use a notification to let
the user know that, hey, the
building is done.
So it kind of reminds you
to get back in the game.
It's a little bit
more engaging.
Now that was kind of a nice way
to do it for that game.
And in those situations, you
definitely want to have that
setting like Tony said, to have
an option to turn that
sort of stuff off.
But that was a clever way of
doing it, because it was
getting the user engaged
more with that title.
You don't want to do it in just
a periodic daily, hey,
have you come and launched
my app recently or
anything like that.
But think about really--
at Google we always talk about
putting the user first.
So think about what is it that
will add value to the user
from your app.
TONY: Yeah.
So I think for the application,
another thing
that may also complement what
they're doing is they can
probably create a
widget as well.
That may be also a good option
to keep the user
engaged with the games.
All right, so that's pretty much
what I have this week for
the presentation.
And let's move on to
Q&A. Ankur, do
you have the moderator?
ANKUR: Well actually the first
moderator question was by
Andrew Kelly, who's live
with us today.
So Andrew, do you want
to just ask live?
ANDREW: Yeah, sure,
no worries.
It was related to, in app
billing, I've got an app that
has in-app purchases
for managed items.
And I was just trying to work
out, if they uninstall the app
from the device and then
reinstall it, I can call a
method to get back their
purchases from the Google Play
store to see what items they've
actually purchased.
But there doesn't seem to be a
way of getting the details of
the individual items that
they've paid for and stuff.
So I was just trying to work
out how I would do that
without having to store
each one in a
database on my server.
ANKUR: Yeah, so typically--
when you do restore
transactions, you are getting
the transactions back, right?
Like the purchases, you're
getting that information,
aren't you?
ANDREW: I don't think so.
The callback method that gets
calls just seems to return a
response object that
says yes or no.
I'm just trying to work out
which part of the API actually
provides the list of--
ANKUR: So what it's supposed to
tell you is, hey, has that
purchase been purchased or
not, is that correct?
I guess, what information are
you trying to glean out of it
in your app?
Because the way restored
transactions from managed
items works is that it basically
tells you, hey,
these are the list of items
that have been purchased.
And just for the audience,
managed items are typically
one-off purchases.
They're not the consumable
type of purchases.
So once you know that you've
purchased a particular item,
you know that it should be
unlocked in your app or
available in your
app throughout.
So it won't give you necessarily
all the same level
of detail that you get when you
purchase the item for the
first time.
But it should at least
tell you--
the API should be telling you,
hey, this particular item ID
has been purchased.
And pretty much on a restore
workflow, that should be
enough to get you through.
If you want to store the extra
information that we do on the
initial purchase, you do need
to store it on a server.
But I guess I'm trying to
understand, is there something
critical that's missing on that
restore transaction that
you're not getting?
ANDREW: Well, I'm just trying to
work out which bit has that
list of information.
Because if I call the restore
transaction, the callback
method is called on restore
transactions response.
And the only two parameters that
get passed back there is
the request and the
response to it.
And the response to it only
seems to say, OK or not OK.
It doesn't seem to have a list
of the actual items as part of
that response.
ANKUR: Oh, I see.
Good question.
I'm just looking that up.
But if Tony or Anirudh, whilst
I'm looking it up, if you guys
know off the top of your head.
ANDREW: I'm using the flag at
the moment, the yes or no flag
that comes back to kind of
hide my [INAUDIBLE].
Because as soon as you make an
in-app purchase, I kind of
remove my advertising.
But the managed items in the
game form a progression.
So you can only buy a level 10
after you've bought level one.
So my shop changes based on
which items you've purchased
previously.
So I need to know those items
so I can change my UI.
Maybe there's a callback that
I haven't got, that I'm
missing or something.
ANKUR: Let me--
I don't know it off the
top of my head.
But what I'll do is, let me
follow up with you after this.
I'll look it up and I'll get
back in touch with you--
ANDREW: No worries.
ANKUR: --and we can take
it from there.
And we'll share the answer on
next week's ADL+ as well.
It's one of those things that
it's hard to know all of this
stuff off the top
of your head.
This is one that we don't know
off the top of our heads.
OK, next question is from Andy
C in Perth, Australia.
Are there any code examples of
using MediaCodec to encode
audio, i.e., PCM to AAC.
I'm having a hard
time finding any
information about this class.
Anirudh or Tony, do you guys
want to chime in here?
ANIRUDH: I just collected a
sample from CBS, [INAUDIBLE]
best suited, which has
a decoder text in it.
And just let me pull
the link up.
So I'm just going to place this
on the Hangout chat so
that you'll be able
to see this.
So I've pulled up the decoder
text, and below that, decoder
[? textPlus, ?]
which explains MediaCodec and
how do you initialize it and
how do you take the
[INAUDIBLE]
to decode.
And below that, I have inserted
some snippets of code.
And they're going to follow
a similar pattern.
These are the encoder
API codes.
So you can probably look at
this and see if you can
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
Let us know how that
goes for you.
ANKUR: All right, cool.
Hey Andrew, I just wanted to
follow up on your question.
And if this isn't sufficient
we will take it offline.
But basically, what should
be happening is
that you should be--
when you do a restore
transaction--
at some point you should be
getting an intent saying
purchase state changed.
And that should be the same
intent that you received when
you first made the purchase.
ANDREW: No worries.
I've got that method
overridden.
So yeah, maybe I just need to
do a little more testing.
ANKUR: Yeah.
So that part of the workflow
should be the same whether
it's the initial purchase
or the restore.
If you do have any issues with
that, reach out to me.
And I'll be happy to help out.
ANDREW: No worries, brilliant.
Thank you.
ANKUR: No problem.
Just a couple of questions
from last week's ADL+.
There was a question about a
developer having some map
activity issues.
We had some discussions offline
and we resolved it.
Basically, if you saw the
question last week, it was
basically along the lines of,
hey, I've got an app that uses
map activities, and on certain
devices I'm noticing that it
crashes on start up.
It turns out that those devices
that they were running
on were not your standard
Android devices that ship with
the Google services.
And so basically, the app was
crashing because Google Maps
didn't exist on that device.
The only situation where you can
get those kind of devices
are devices that are not your
Google Play certified devices.
So anything that ships with
Google Play, which is where
this develop was distributing
their app, should have Google
Maps on it.
I pointed that developer also
towards some code that they
could add in their app where,
at start up, they could
statically check with the map
activity classes available.
And if it's not, then degrade
the experience.
So that their app doesn't crash,
but it doesn't provide
the map capability that
might be there.
So we were able to
resolve that.
The other question that we had
last week that was unresolved
was also to do with referrals.
So if you've got an installation
referral, and you
pass in referral IDs, about that
not being passed around
so that they weren't able to
track when apps were installed
as a result of other apps
referring them.
Basically, the resolution there
was that they needed to
use a URL as opposed
to an intent.
The information that's passed
in an intent is not
necessarily used.
And what they should be doing is
passing in a Play URL with
the extra parameters
at the end.
And then the referral
ID should get
passed through correctly.
So that's all the questions
that are up this week.
Is there anything else, Anirudh
or Tony, you guys
wanted to add?
No?
All right, well thanks everyone
for tuning in.
We will see you again next
week at the same time.
Until then, see you later.
Oh, and don't forget to continue
looking at the ADL+
experiments.
We're keeping an eye out
for those submissions.
All right, thank you.
See you later.
Bye Andrew.
ANDREW: See you.